c'est comme les girard ou les césar mais
je vous dis ça avec plus de mixité et le
jean kader de la boulette est attribué à
antoine diers ce qui a fait une gaffe
sur la prochaine candidature d'eric
zemmour regarde
les gérants kader de la boulette c'est
un lit doit
des amis qui produit des cravates des
choses comme ça dès qu'il m'a demandé de
le remettre à eric zemmour et quand
l'odyssée vous offre une cravate
globalement c'est bon signe puisque il
en a offert à emmanuel macron à nicolas
sarkozy a tous des gens qui ont gagné
donc c'est le début de la de la victoire
alors
je fais encore candidat non telle
observation
[Rires]
mellie francon une bière ce qui est le
président des amis d'eric zemmour parle
exactement il accusant porte parole des
amis d'eric zemmour ouais ce qu'il a il
ya plein d'amis et donc il est fort
porte parole je sais pas si vous n'avez
plus un tabou
je pourrais être pas de parole des amis
de franck gastambide voilà lui il est
comme ça ils vont craquer le champ kader
de l'académie française est attribué à
cyril hanouna pour son passé digne d'un
professeur de linguistique dont on est
en direct sur france bleu ciel pendant
une bataille
jean qu'aider jacques demy française
ça a été un point de voilà un point
d'achoppement entre lui et le président
ou emmanuel macron il va dit lâche un
petit peu du la statue un islamiste
notoire sur le plateau il c'est fait
c'est fait fortement houspiller vous
avez eu des partis politiques se sont
emparés mis là pour en faire un porte
drapeau il faut arrêter aussi avec les
antilles vax de comme je dis à chaque
fois que les cornées risée de jour en
jour
[Rires]
en plus tous pliés
sais c'est pas franchement c'est mon qui
m'est venue j'ai dit tiens ont supplié
delphine sata plus tard 70e alors je
voulais regarder et je suis resté et je
me suis endormi renom
j'appelle le charisme quand elle a
commencé à 23h30 j'ai regardé sur le
programme la femme 2h30 de film quand
même envoyé un sms avant pour me dire je
vais te regarder ouais et oui et non je
suis allé aux écoutes c'est comme avec
guillaume genton et croit toujours qu'il
va taper chaume évidemment un truc de
kenneth marais genton à 22h d'or
non mais non mais cela dit ces valeurs
nous ça faisait plusieurs jours qu'on
s'appelle en se disant comment on va
rester les deux sérieux donc on a évité
les risques contact avec la mission à
voulait pas se regarder il est arrivé
comme s'il me connaissaient pas il a
fait sa perte parce que yann il ya deux
mots de travers mais il envoie une
perforation crois moi j'étais assez
impressionné de par mon pote et et on
sait pas regarder pour éviter de gaulle
rihaoui et ensuite quand ça a été mon
tour
ouais bah oui non mais franchement
c'était un beau souvenir se tient plus
on voulait le faire ensemble puis
c'était un standard et c'est vrai qu'on
était en somme allant dans cette
émission d'une séquence qui a énormément
fait parler sur les réseaux ce week-end
c'est celle avec pierre arditi la tenue
intervenir à propos de la présence des
politiques showman sur notre plateau
regardez ce qu'il dit et fabrice di
vizio vient nous faire un coucou parce
qu'il voulait absolument réagir sur
cette séquence fabrice et voilà fabrice
elle en plus ça nous fait plaisir de le
revoir fabrice ça fait longtemps je vais
vous dire non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
ça fait longtemps c'est comme vous
nicolas nov c'est fou mais vous à mon
avis vous êtes on vous a vraiment sorti
du niveau on dirait
c'est pas bon présage
oh oui merci
des
gens mais si aujourd'hui c'est plus un
homme politique dans la tête des gens
c'est un showman donc est ce que demain
on va voter pour un show man je suis pas
sûr après jour monsieur jean missia bon
c'est pas très à la mode en ce moment
oui c'est vrai non mais ça il ya
beaucoup de showman qui outre ' a prévu
il ya forcément un conte fait mieux on a
les héros qu'on mérite ouais on est
engagé bagarrer contre ça mais moi
personnellement j'aurais plutôt tendance
à me bagarrer contre ça mais c'est ça
aux acteurs c'est leur métier ils vont
font ça beaucoup mieux que l'an passé
sur ce qu'ils font de la politique et
que c'est bien de faire de la politique
en allant dans des shows télévisés on
leur demande pas d'aller dans les shows
télévisés on leur demande de règles
résoudre des problèmes pour que les
hommes et les femmes aillent moins mal
mieux un message aux rôles en fonction
le reste on est absolument rien à vous
mais vous remarquerez servira un makila
ce père au dernier degré j'en ai marre
de ça on aura les héros qu'on méritait
on finira le cap à créer des générations
qui finiront par prendre un spot
publicitaire pour une tragédie de racine
alors sam en lice et c'est souvent ceux
qui sont pas au pouvoir qui font le plus
de télé alors fabrice merci d'être là
c'est alors je vais te dire tu nous as
manqué
woods a savamment fabrice à ce qu'on t'a
manqué non
open les personnes qui m'ont même mois
[Rires]
parce que qu'est ce que parce que moi
j'avais un peu la cote un peu sinon
ouais c'est vrai du tout un petit peu
c'est lui qui anime donc voilà vous
connaissez franck gastambide on
va les regarder
découvrez les jambes ou bas je
connaissais pas non non je m'engage sur
leurs actifs je connais s'est pas moqué
à oui c'est vrai si les gones insulte
tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
blague à part on y admire fois que je
venais ici quand j'ai dit je vais chez
cyril janin tu vas chez stella luna un
essai qui est en fait dit voilà c'était
le graal maintenant maintenant je
connais ça merci à fabriquer vidéo
franchement moi c'est le graal de vous
recevoir alors c'est vrai que cette
séquence à la fait énormément on est un
peu en asra francky totalement
totalement en détention parce qu'on est
encore arrivé après moi je me suis
cognée dès le début mais
c'est vrai qu'on a vraiment j'ai pas
compris on t'accuse à qui s'adresser
après l'émission il est né très
sympathique nul d'entre sympathiquement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous on peut oser dire qu'ils n'ont pas
été très sympa quoi c'est vrai moi
j'espère faire d'études à la gravité des
faits le replay 10 comment tu l'a
ressenti c'est pas vrai je veux dire et
je supportais pas tant pas
non mais le début de mission avant que
tu arrives et mamie mois dans des petits
moments un peu gênant on en a parlé avec
raymond tout à l'heure qui je ne savais
pas mais moi j'ai trouvé eux laurent il
y as exceptionnelles font jouer
maintenant si tu veux bien précisé que
je parle pas de
moi je serai très content de faire
l'émission mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un
moment je me sentais totalement en
décalage avec ces gens mais christophe
talmet combat l'invité des ans qui était
en rébellion avec toute la modernité
tout ce qui est nouveau tout ce qui est
tu vas aimer un peu pardon avec tout le
respect que je lui dois un peu comme des
vieux cons
alors là moi j'ai rarement senti même à
l'antenne que pierre arditi il était
agacé voire jaloux que c'était vous la
star de l'émission est pas lui et j'ai
chronométré en fait ils ont fait onze
minutes sur lui et 43 minutes sur vous
donc ça s'est vraiment senti à l'antenne
et je pense qu'il était dégoûté et ça se
voyait dans son regard sa santé dans ses
propos et c'est bizarre tout ça le
dérangeait pas devenir honte et bmp ya
quelques années donc ça va être chaud
samaoui j'ai chanté avec lui et moi j'ai
pas seulement mais ça n'est pas très
sympa
c'était plus globale y voilà c'est ce
qu'il reprochait c'était le fait que des
hommes politiques viennent se fourvoyer
sur des plateaux de télévision dit de
divertissement sauf que ce qu'il a
oublié on l'a pas entendu à l'époque où
bach dare-dare dit demandez à rocard est
ce que sucer c'est tromper on l'a pas
entendu cheveux retenus pour vous dire
change actuel on l'a pas entendu quand
quand il y avait patrick sébastien qui
recevait giscard qui jouait de
l'accordéon et c'est donc pourquoi tout
d'un coup ça tombe sur vous maintenant
alors que c'est quelque chose les
politiques qui font du jeu qui font du
show ça date d'il ya déjà vingt ans que
l'espagne où il ya une raison logique à
tout ça c'est qu'à un moment donné il ya
un décalage et les personnes âgées ils
partent un petit plomb dans les prisons
quand je vois le monde moderne
la société actuelle et là c'était 10 à
40 ans et c'est normal je croyais en
question d'âge jusqu'où m une
demi-finale à sochaux
devrait on dire et quoi faire un massage
à la pierre chaude
c'est pour ça qu'on voit un gros
décalage essai personnel ce rendu compte
de ce qui est possible ou pas et et à un
moment donné bon ils savent plus où ils
sont ils sont perdus dans le monde
actuel et il repense souvent ils sont
gros saljic des années 10 à 40 ça les
rend un petit peu aigri et mal dans leur
peau et focus était vous avez quand ils
sont versés mathieu de l'an passé
beaucoup plus simple que ça on est on
est sur ce qui touche un petit peu
souvent les artistes et souvent d'une
ancienne génération type rem dgo pendant
trente minutes ça parlait pas d'eux est
uniquement 2 et du coup s'est intéressée
par ces eaux c'est aussi bête que ça et
on voit qu'ils s'ennuient on voit que
derrière il reprend souvent la parole
pour ramener sa pièce alors qu'on parle
d'autre chose et c'est vrai que c'est
dommage qu'il découvre pas un peu la
nouvelle génération de soi francou vous
et cc oui c'était il y avait un peu
d'aigreur fabrice foot toi tu étais tu
étais triste en fait je pense que ce
propos est juste débile c'est tout là
beaucoup plus tranché que c'est un pari
ville en fait savoir d'après dans
l'intérêt tout à l'heure on dise oui le
problème des politiques qui font du faux
nom ce qui lui ce qu'il dérange c'est
qu'ils considèrent que certaines
personnes ne devraient pas faire de la
politique c'est ça c'est ça qui dit il
dit finalement des gens comme jean
bessière et serra ne devrait pas faire
de politique d'abord d'abord en lui rien
demandé ça c'est le premier point est
donc c'est sympa donner son avis quand
on ne demande pas mais en l'occurrence
effectivement leur est demandé passé le
premier point est le deuxième point
c'est un téléski ce que pense pierre
arditi
c'est que ça mais moi je crois que tu
connais pas
réussir il a dit ça pourquoi tu dis ça
mais c'est vrai c'est ce que pierre
arditi si vous laissez cette spécialité
très française de paraître sujet qu'on
connaît pas généralement donné c'est pas
à lui de décider qui fait de la
politique et qui n'en fait pas non mais
géré cela qu'il appartient de décider 1
ces législateurs et 2 c'est finalement
au peuple qui vote après leur avoir
donné son abri où la fin il a droit à
son avis il imprime ses vrais sujets
qu'ils connaissaient pas bien non mais
ce qu'ils ne
savent même pas qui était jours mais si
c'est ça je pense que c'est pas qu'ils
en aient sûreté jamais s'y entassent e
santé oui barda moi je pense vraiment
que ça l'a desservi certes c'est un
excellent acteur on veut pas lui nier ça
en revanche la sava desservies en plus
il a fini sur une critique très mauvaise
il termine en disant que bientôt un spot
de pub ça sera ils ont souffert comme du
corneille il vaut mieux shakespeare et
ça c'est très méprisant si mais c'est
très bizarre et une voiture à friction
ville il s'élance et s'est lancée et
après il devenait de plus en plus
virulents la voiture a
exigé d'elle prado vous avez évoqué
effectivement ça répertoire d'ailleurs
train par exemple mais en fait cette
vision qu'on a de la politique par les
deux shows il faut aller aux états unis
y voir comment se passent les campagnes
électorales aux tats-unis tiens c'est du
show chaussée c'est presque c'est
pratiquement que ça d'ailleurs venir et
donc c'est intéressant parce qu'ils
n'ont pas de plafonnement des campagnes
etc donc il ya vraiment du show on
utilise la télé depuis trente ou
quarante ans maintenant pour faire sa
pub on a vraiment des campagnes de pub
sur les candidats voit sa frappe et ça
ça m'a frappé et donc on a une vision de
la politique est quand même très
française est très protocolaire et
aujourd'hui finalement là où je suis
assez d'accord avec tout le monde c'est
sûr un moment donné c'est pas à pierre
arditi de décider de qui a la légitimité
ou pas pour faire de la politique en
fait c'est aux électeurs de le faire et
c'est quand même un des gros problèmes
dans ce pays c'est qu'un abandonner tout
le monde parle à la place des électeurs
et si on laissait juste par les
électeurs qua non mais il reprochait
surtout à cyril de donner la parole aux
gens un peu radicaux aux extrêmes à ceux
qui montent aujourd'hui c'est ça ce qui
est reproché cette deuxième
c'est quand on leur donne pas la parole
que justement il progresse et donc
c'était ça sera comme ça c'était pas
grand chose ça a été monté en ligne sur
les réseaux sociaux oui week-end voilà
en tout cas un record d'audience paul
ont requis samedi soir donc on était
très content d'y être franck mois et
pierre arditi d'ailleurs aussi voilà
donc records d'audience plus d'un
million de téléspectateurs et offert à
midi pas moi
tandis que c'était que cette histoire de
boxe parce qu'il vous voyez vous l'avez
expliqué dans l'émission et j'en faisais
mais c'est quoi ces box non non non non
on en reparlera quand je referai
l'émission de grands pas mais je le
dirai merci
il a dit ça ralentit le débat non
raconte yves jamait le débat et une
voiture à friction
[Applaudissements]